ah do I have to go to this thing today
yep all the other regional managers are
bringing their spouses Wow so thrilling
there is no way you're getting out of
this but what if there was a way
introducing the foolproof way to get out
of any social engagement erase your
necks erasing ex is he only
over-the-counter drug that erases you
from existence have fun just one pill
here hop the hook use a race you necks
to get out of your friends one-person
show
studies show that existing is the number
one cause of social anxiety and the best
cure is not existing at all for example
I hate being a commercial actor will
reassemble on top of the random mountain
it's Regis seven months later almost as
good as new which means you can use to
race your necks again and again
use your ASEAN X to get out of important
presentation I think I'd use your AC
next to get out of Thanksgiving the thin
lies
[Music]
Dadar racier net right for you racer
neck size effects include mild dizziness
mister mildness it's Laura affected the
juice ice essential chills this is until
never the scream of Newark for announced
the realization eternal knowledge he
exposed to constipation ticket to the
best attorney to be sold to protect
service ad indeed
[Applause]
you